my lovely genius farts during this Prime
spring season you need wholesome
convenient meals to energize you for
warmer more active days and keep you on
track to reaching your goals Sun Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit can help you feel a fast but ready
to eat meals deliver straight to your
door and the cool thing about factor
that I personally enjoy the most my
friends is that 34 plus Chef prepared
dietitian approved weekly options so if
you get tired of something else you
could try something new head to
factormeals.com geniusbrain50 and use
code to use spray 50 to get 50 off your
first box that's code geniusbrain50 at
Factor meals.com 50 to get 50 off your
first box this podcast is brought to you
by zoc doc my friends you've been suing
about a health problem you have well
guess what I bet you're resorting to
testing your group chat to get your
friends opinions about things that they
don't know about your extremely unlikely
to find the quality medical advice
that's out there in your group chat but
you can find it from a doctor on zoc.com
is the only free app that lets you find
a book doctors who are patient reviewed
take your insurance are available when
you need them and treat almost every
condition Under the Sun go to zocdoc.com
genius and download the ZocDoc app for
free then find and book a top rated
doctor today many are available within
24 hours at zocdoc.com slash genius
zocdoc.com genius
but I know it's ridiculous right
obviously we don't live in a zombie
apocalypse but it does put into
perspective of like what people complain
about
there's a reason why I don't like people
who whine right yeah and I'm not saying
that we don't go through our own trials
and tribulations because a lot of the
times when when I when you hear
something from somebody like me or
anybody else when they go through
something
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast I am your host
David so and we have my reoccurring
co-host Ed Park my friends uh a lot of
you guys out there don't know because
some of you just listened to the audio
there are two head parks
and apparently both you guys voices
sound very [__] familiar yeah yeah I
think it's that that Smoker's voice
that's what it is yeah there's two Ed
Parks there's edrick Park the guy that I
do a secret society uh the Contemporary
uh fashion Basics line that I that I
have and then there's Ed Park the guy
that was my roommate right also we did
video work together two separate people
for the people who are listening on uh
the audio side
um for a while now we have sat on doing
this review we haven't done a movie or
show review in quite a while actually
um and before we go into beef we're
gonna do the last of us because we owe
it to them for the last half now the
first half of the Last of Us was [__]
intense yeah and mind you once again I
did not play the game I had no idea what
the show was going to be about and this
show took me by surprise of how [__]
good it is and was yeah right obviously
star-studded cast
everybody is on their [__] game not a
single person whether they played a
small role in this series is a terrible
actor they are all [__] they're all
amazing yeah and one of the things that
I do enjoy uh hearing about even though
I didn't play the game is how much
people who were Avid fans of this game
truly enjoy this show and how they're
keeping it very close to the source
material yes once again for me it
doesn't really matter I never play the
game but to understand that they
actually they had the original writer or
Creator the original Creator writer
director he did all of that for the
video game and then they paired him up
with the guy who made Chernobyl on HBO
oh and so that's why we have a solid
[__] adaptation it's so damn good so
the last episode that we stopped on
stopped on was episode five right and
that was with the black the the deaf kid
the deaf kid yeah and where you know
there they saw their demise and then
Ellie and Joel have to keep moving on
Westward yes from Kansas City and that
episode was [__] devastating that she
shook me to my [__] core I played the
game once and I only played it once
because it's too scary to play again for
me but all I remember was this is such a
good [__] game that I'll never play
again yeah yeah and so I remember the
beginning and I remember the end I
totally forgot everything in the middle
so when that scene happened I was
utterly shocked as well again all over
again so it was great to experience it
again the same way let's go let's go
into episode six since you guys have all
been waiting so I obviously we watched
this a while back I watched it again uh
yesterday and
I sometimes forget
how the the thing I appreciate about
this show so much is that it's not just
banking on its fandom right yeah a lot
of the times when series or just shows
whether it's comic book series or
whatever when they Bank on the fandom
they kind of get away with a lot of
shitty acting writing and storytelling
yeah right yeah but even on episode six
what I enjoyed the most about it is
right from the jump is how [__]
entertaining the dialogue is yes so in
the scene
they're traveling because he's a Joel is
looking for his brother right it's been
a few months since the last episode it's
now winter yeah it's now winter and they
meet this Native American couple and bro
that [__] cracked me the [__] up you
know when you think about it too like on
it in itself with the writing on the
paper it's nothing without the right
actors on the screen having that kind of
they seem like a couple who've been
together for over 50 years yeah you know
they're bickering and they're back and
forth is just so money like they don't
give a [__] they don't give a [__] they
never gave a [__] even before the
Apocalypse
except for the wife she said I never
wanted to leave yeah yeah she's adorable
yeah so Joel
and Ellie find this cabin and they
obviously infiltrated it and they're
kind of quote-unquote holding this lady
hostage waiting for a husband and he has
a gun he pulls a gun on him tells him to
sit down and ask him where he's at
trying to confirm that he's not lying
about their location but this dude is so
just what I don't give a [__] yeah
he's just sitting there he goes did you
tell him the real location yes
the real okay yes
they're such a great couple but um the
essence of the scene is
um Joel
looking for his brother so he's looking
for on the map where he could be
according to where their location is and
they say any further west of the river
or some I forget Which Way but it's dead
Valley like nobody goes through and
comes back alive and such
and they intimate like they say like if
your brother's out there he's probably
dead yeah right and then Ellie goes you
can't scare us and then she goes I
scared him
because Joel is shook his Shook at the
thought that his brother might be dead
you know after all these years
and so they leave the cabin and uh Ellie
steals a [__] rabbit and Joel has a
[__] panic attack
what's going on and he's like shut up
like nothing it's like manly mans it out
yeah and they keep walking and they come
to the river that they speak of they see
a hydro plant like a hydro plant uh Dam
right
um
and that's when the group of people on
their on Horseback with their guns come
in surround them they do the dog test uh
where the dog can sniff if they're
infected or not yeah and uh pass the
test relief of tension and they bring
him in to take them to the commune
um and so when they come in this commune
is a [__] Utopia compared to
everything we've seen yeah yeah it's
everything is working and Joel spots his
brother uh [__] this is about his name
Tom
incredibly relieved and they catch up
they have a meal and then we learn that
um
the lady who had you know had their you
know guns pointed at him is Tommy's wife
yeah where now that Joel has
been there he thinks he's there to save
Tommy Tommy's like I'm been okay I'm
fine yeah right and he has all these
plans of what they're going to do not
that he's alive he's like I have a life
here this is my wife you know and you
know this is what I'm doing I'm not
doing anything this is such a weird part
for me because I you know up until this
point in the show you actually don't
know much about Joel right you just know
that he's a very guarded human being
because of the death of his daughter
yeah right this episode for me what the
way that Tommy was kind of treating his
brother kind of gave me a glimpse into
how vicious
a Joel is right and Tommy is like semi
afraid of afraid of him like his own
brother this is like how Joel loves his
brother obviously his brother loves him
back right and we've seen this in the
beginning of the episode when he saved
him and everything else they have a
great relationship but there's parts of
the story that's missing that
we don't know about Joel yeah he has a
reputation to himself right you know
what I mean the reputation being that
he's a killer he's a [__] killer but
what do they mean by killer right and it
turns out that Joel used to be a part of
fedra yeah he used to stand light and he
would kill innocent people like the way
they did if they were infected or not it
was an emerging situation and he was one
of those soldiers when he was telling
that story to Ellie back in episode
three that's something he sounds like he
participated in and Tommy was doing that
they say because he was
trying to survive with his brother and
just following his brother but it was
not something he wanted to do and Joel's
argument was like that's what that's the
same for me too I was just trying to
survive you know there's a weird moment
too where
obviously you know we're seeing a lot of
Joel's human side yeah and there's a
point in the film where you're going
around you get to see the world that
they've created right they have movie
Nights right
um you see like the horses in the
stadium livestock they they have all
different kinds of
um religious backgrounds too and then
they're like we're Communists
Joel KISS Tommy a dirty look yeah
communist yeah oh yeah he's from Texas
yeah
copy yes
um and uh they have a they have a very
heart-to-heart moment and this moment
man I gotta tell you the level of acting
of Pedro Pascal is [__] amazing man
when he was sitting there
cling to his brother to take Ellie in
right right and kind of telling like
exposing himself about how like the
heinous stuff that he's done like he
knows it he knows how terrible are you
talking about um later at night right
yeah yeah before that where they're in
the bar they have some contention too
because he wanted a I want to speak
alone with my brother and then what
we're seeing and from Joel's side is
like all these years I thought
you could have been dead and everything
I did to keep going was to find you and
make sure alive and you're just
yeah
and then his brother is like just
because life stopped for you doesn't
mean it'll stop for me yeah and you
start noticing that relationship that
Joel has with Tommy in their brotherly
relationship is pretty toxic yeah for
him to drag his own brother into his
misery because his daughter died yeah
you know but he's like and then he
reveals my wife's pregnant she has a
baby coming and so all these things that
you have planned you want me to go with
you to take this girl over there like no
yeah now I have my own girl to take care
of and then that's where they get an
arguments like that's not even your
daughter yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
and
then I guess uh I guess he leaves that
bar in like anger and he gets another
panic attack and he sees an image of
what I'm guessing is a mixed girl with
big curly hair and sees what he thinks
is his daughter but this girl has her
own daughter and then you can see that
if if you're just reading character that
he must be thinking if his daughter was
still alive yeah to this day you know I
think a lot of people had mixed feelings
about that moment right because he saw
that on Twitter people were saying well
Joel's not a [__] he doesn't get panic
attacks yeah yeah [__] like that people
people have very mixed feelings and I
think that sometimes
when people watch shows like this right
there is an image of a person that you
see that that the writing shows on a
surface level right but you're not
looking into all the little Easter eggs
the show's giving you yeah right about
how complex this human being is even
that relationship between him and his
brother I think a lot of people didn't
understand because they they're only
looking at it from the view of
oh Joel is over here sacrificing his
comfort and his life to find his brother
how dare his [__] brother you know
just sit here and enjoy his life while
his brothers actually who loves him is
looking for him he didn't look for his
brother that's right but so you can
understand Joel's resentment yeah that
sense but that's not the whole picture
it's not the whole guy you were
controlling on the controller so you
have this attachment to this character
yeah but in that's that's another thing
I want to bring up
um is the fact that the people who
didn't like the show were saying oh it's
not like the game it's like yeah because
it's a [__] game it's interactive you
control the character and I think you
make these decisions kind of thing
that's what it takes away from but
that's the [__] reality of [__]
movies all right there's no
smell-o-vision quite yet yeah yeah yeah
all right you know we're working on it
with 3D yeah so it's like you know chill
the [__] out and respect the medium and
it's telling you the [__] story yeah
and that's and so how I would have done
it it's like yeah but you were playing a
game yeah and now we actually get to see
what humans actually are like when they
interact with each other and obviously
like sibling relationships are very
complicated you know and there's
something that happened between them
that even we don't really know about but
they can only allude to it through their
conversations his brother almost seems
to me from that he's like I almost want
to forget everything that we did in the
past yeah right you're trying to move me
and take me into this world that I've
been trying to forget for the longest
time I found a new life I'm happy here
yeah it's safe yeah let me live in this
reality and I think for him he's
accepted like this is this is what it is
and we are going to live here right you
know and his brother obviously has a
different Mission and he's not really
considering the fact that his brother
has a new life he goes no you're my
brother you come with me yeah you know
which culminates to the meeting I don't
know if it was like a hardware store or
some [__] um
yeah he's sitting alone in the dark in
his Tommy comes and finds him and Joel
finds it we see what all those panic
attacks were about what was creeping up
on him was this sense of [__] failure
that he's failed when his daughter died
he failed when Tess died if you know and
you know at the cabin that panic attack
was the real reality that his brother
might be dead but now that his brother
is alive
it's that's not enough for him the fact
that his brother is alive but that he's
gonna go alone with Ali into with the
rest of this Mission and him seeing that
image of his daughter gave him that
panic attack feeling that sinking
feeling like he's going to fail this
I'm going to fail this too because I
failed at everything and so now you see
the alpha character you know actually
start being vulnerable you know the only
person he could be vulnerable with is
his brother yeah and so this whole time
what he couldn't be for years and why he
was so hardened was and why he couldn't
be real with anyone
you know was he didn't have that person
with him which was his brother and when
he opens up like that and he's saying
like you gotta take her I'm gonna get
her killed yeah to the point where his
brother finally agrees because he tells
him she's immune you know and so he sees
the bigger picture and the bigger
Mission so his brother accepts
but then Joel now has to go talk to Ali
about what's gonna happen
what's interesting is when he walks into
the bedroom that she's staying in she's
reading a diary
and she says is this what everyone had
to worry about what kind of shirt
matches with their skirts and talking to
boys it's so bizarre
you know and the world was like before
everything else yeah and all these
things we still take for granted yeah
you know
um because yeah that was pretty poignant
for me like to really look at how much
like where our world's at and then the
reality these people and I [__] loved
that part right
um I'm not sure if that part was either
in the game or not or if it's a
consistent Trope in the game
but I know it's ridiculous right
obviously we don't live in a zombie
apocalypse but it does put into
perspective of like what people complain
about
there's a reason why I don't like people
who whine right yeah and I'm not saying
that we don't go through our own trials
and tribulations because a lot of the
times when when I when you hear
something from somebody like me or
anybody else when they go through
something and we we hear them out we
Comfort them and then we try to give
them an alternative perspective people
also go oh you're dismissive of my
feelings or your perspective is [__]
and what you're complaining about isn't
that big of a deal and you're allowing
these things to eat you up yeah life is
short yeah you know but like her
last fight you know look
you know we talk a lot about our
Christian faith and what what has
happened in our religion right but one
of the things that I'm very grateful for
is missionary trips yeah missionary
trips put a huge perspective in my life
that I never experienced before because
I truly people can tell you as much as
you want there are people out there who
are starving who don't have what you
have you should be grateful it's all
words yeah when you see it in person
yeah it [__] flips your script like
none other happier people too somehow
yeah they're not happy bro I even they
didn't like I'll forever remember this
in uh and uh because I only I went on
two mission trips obviously one was to
Mexico but talking to the kids out there
right whether you have a translator and
they tell you what they're saying to you
and I'm scared of these stray dogs and
this kid's laughing at me and and then
the guy's translating his Spanish to me
and he goes he finds it funny that
you're scared of these dogs when God is
walking with you every day
[__] child yeah
yeah you use your perspective on things
and you don't hear them complaining
about life or whatever you know this is
this is like what has happened to how we
live now yeah by Twitter why it's so
easy for us to complain about everything
because actually things are so [__]
great that the thing that you're worried
about the most is whether somebody calls
users and
right which yeah is a real problem for
you I understand
you know this is just a society this is
how great things are yeah but
if you if if you kind of put things in
perspective I felt like a lot of the
times like for me when I was younger I
didn't complain a lot either because I
was so worried about just [__] paying
my bills yeah it's kind of going on
about life if you kind of put in
perspective of like how great things are
it's kind of trippy and when you that
that little diary moment was that yeah
you know so
um that that Trope will keep coming up
in in subsequent episodes
um but they have a big falling out where
he tells her like you're not my daughter
[__] him vicious dude just [__] it right
and she's like go ahead then leave me
just like everybody else she's she's
essentially feeling what he feels and
like that whole conversation that she
had is like damn you're like talking
into your reflection and he has to hear
that [__] and she says I've lost people
too I know what it is
to lose and then he tells her no you
don't you don't know what it's like to
lose which is a false statement
something he doesn't we'll learn we'll
talk about it in the next episode
but he they leave the room
and he goes back to his spot
and then he has this flashback of
Christmas and his daughter
and then
I think that alone like hearkens back to
his whole reason why he's even there as
much as he keeps saying my brother my
brother I'm there go see my brother the
reality was his brother's perfectly fine
yeah he went there with because he's
protecting Ali he went there because of
what the entire reason through whether
tests imparted in him or not
was that you know this is someone that
is like his second chance at saving
somebody like his daughter yeah you know
and doing something greater and bigger
like the way his daughter was it was
just this sweet girl yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's interesting because you know I
mean I guess I kind of expected it but
in the way he's so such a macho dude
even the so Ellie obviously ends up
going with him but you know if they're
at the stable yeah he'll listen I
deserve to give you a choice he goes I'm
going with you immediately immediately
you know like not even a psych didn't
even need a thought right but it's funny
how he opened it up like yeah I was just
stealing this horse yeah
I'll be all manly about it we would have
given it to you yeah because I know
well this episode ends with
um they get to the
the life yeah yeah where they think that
they're going to be nobody's there
so when they come out of it there's
these Marauders the Raiders yeah who
attack them
and Joel fights one off and breaks the
guy's a baseball bat it breaks the bat
and then boom clap I think he breaks his
neck [__] him up kills him out and then
Ali's like oh [__] Joel and he got
stabbed with the end of the [__] bat
dude [__] Jack dude yeah you know
what the part that [__] annoyed me
not not from a film perspective it's
like these guys came to jump and kill
him
and then the people who came there was
like they came back and they're like I
can't believe you did this to my friends
it's like
[Music]
[__] are you talking about
well
um the getaway but Joel falls off the
horse later and he's dying and Ellie
tells him like you can't [__] die
because I'll die you know like I can't
do this without you fade the black
so going into our next episode
she's dragged him into this abandoned
neighborhood this house takes him into
the basement
um
doesn't know what the [__] to do she's
like telling Joe what do I do what do I
do what do I do he grabs her and he says
just get out of here leave me you have
to leave me
you know and tells her to go pushes her
away
and she does her
usual attitude [__] you thing turns
around to leave she stops at the
stairwell and then we flash back and
this is the rest of the episode
um where
basically what happened chronologically
before we saw you know the current day
is
we see
ephedra is on the inside
Ellie is going to this military school
it looks like a regular High School just
stuck in time yeah you know she's
getting bullied she punches a girl
because the girl makes a joke about
Ellie's friend right who used to fight
for her but now she's gone
and so Ali fights her then she gets put
into
um what I'm assuming is a school
Authority like uh but he's a military
guy
and then
he tells her he gives her the pep talk
about what life is like you know you're
one of the smartest brightest if you
just did what I'm telling you to do you
know you don't have to go outside of the
walls you could stay inside go ahead
just do an admin job get the best food
you can get a hot shower you know you
know have your own spot this and that
don't you don't have to scrounge around
like everybody else
where
you know she's like okay fine you know
like what what we're getting as an
audience in this scene and is how federa
is
just like every other
idea that's going around is just trying
to survive yeah you know although they
are fascists
like on the inside it's like all these
people bureaucratic people just trying
to live just trying to survive their
reality
and so the next scene we're seeing Ellie
in a room
um and the other bed in her bunk the
whoever she's sharing the room with is
completely empty she's missing we're
assuming that's her friend that's
missing she thinks she's been dead so
Ellie's been worried and then our friend
busts in to surprise her
and so they basically just have this big
adventure where she takes her to the
mall
right and in the mall
um she has this whole thing set up for
Ellie you know because they're such
close friends like she wants to show her
the wonders of the mall something Ellie
has never seen or experienced
and like they take go to a photo booth
they go to Arcade they do such things
but they also what's going on is they're
like talking about why they are where
they are and Ellie not knowing anything
better then I guess this is a life you
know it says I do a federal federal says
and I'll just be part of fedra
but for her friend I'm like forgetting
her name this is an important character
to the show this episode too people
hated this episode by the way yeah yeah
I hear that a lot they [__] hated
this episode like they did not like it
at all and I understand people's
sentiments right
I think
there's definitely a lot of like good
information for you to understand who
Ellie is before everything else right
because we never really got a backstory
of this girl are we just gonna know
about billing yeah and and his whole
situation and his whole Love Story yeah
and we do Ellie yeah and I think what
happened was because of that there was a
comparison between bill and his love
story and this because it's kind of
revealed that Ellie is uh is gay yeah
right that friend of hers is like she's
in love with her yeah right and I think
because they had this whole beautiful
setup for bill and his partner that this
one kind of fell short for everybody
yeah it just kind of seemed like
they people enjoyed the backstory of
kind of who her character was in the
federal school system This Love Story
served no purpose for them right yeah
this part of the story though is
actually it was a DLC of the game I
remember playing this part
um but it came out afterwards as like
Ellie's Side Story where you just play
as her okay and where she came from so
they included it into the story if you
notice this whole season is completely
non-linear we time jump all over the
place all the time yeah yeah yeah and I
understand that too like how it is
important
but the second time around was I was
watching I skipped it I skipped it till
they got to the dialogue so I can
understand why they're there now that
I've given credit the episode I hated
this episode I thought it was [__]
useless as [__] I don't think we [__]
need I think we needed the first half
yeah but their love really you know it's
like anything that that you watch right
when you don't set up a why for the what
you don't [__] care yeah their love
interesting I could give a [__] less
about right you know what I mean first
is the other Bill episode you got to see
why their love was important right
this was kind of it it could have just
been her friend it could have been
anything
I'm going to defend this episode even
though it is slow
I'm gonna defend its purpose and the
reason why it's in there and the whole
point of it being a DLC because it
wasn't in the original release of the
game
um apparently they hadn't finished that
part until they released it later as a
DLC
because you know we're already talking
about the show you know it serves its
purpose at the end of the show because
Ellie had approval Point not pro point
but reiterate the fact that she has lost
people but Joel didn't believe her yeah
we were just saying in the last episode
and
the
so for that purpose I understand so they
had the DLC the show Ellie's story about
what she's talking about she's lost end
of the game yeah well she's lost
the other part of me
and you can call it Aegis if you want to
is I think
I am not a fan
of today's Hollywood
catering gen Z into everything I know
what you're saying and that was the
biggest critique of this episode yeah
Ant-Man and the WASP it's called Ant-Man
and the WASP except it was about Ant-Man
and his daughter
yeah and so the whole thing we were
talking about the other time before was
Evangeline Lily who is the titular
character her character is in the
[__] title has nothing to do in the
movie instead everything's going on with
um ant-man's daughter
and what the [__] is she even doing
yeah yeah yeah what is their purpose and
like just look at everything and even
her character is for like you just went
through a huge trauma where you thought
your dad was dead for five years and you
had a whole life without him and then he
came back and everybody came back except
you're just perfectly fine happily
bubbly no issues about it and instead
it's about how gen Z can rise up and
take up power and fight and be
superheroes it's a very childish way of
saying yeah yeah
you know and then Thor love and Thunders
just like kidnap children you know okay
Guardians of the Galaxy kidnap children
oh okay there's always this like
catering to that but when you look at
why they would do it it's because oh
kids love MCU kids are the ones that
love Iron Man but look at the first Iron
Man it's not a [__] kids movie yeah
yeah yeah it's not at all it's it's hard
PG-13 I mean we're seeing this a lot in
like television shows and film and the
thing about that is it's if people
haven't figured it out
people only go where the money is and
they're trying to figure it out their
whole marketing is based on that right
yeah which you know film and TV shows
suffer from it because they're just
trying to figure out a way to get the
most eyes on this even if like the story
suffers from it and you know it's it's
the Hollywood [__] game right we've
seen it so many times that's why I'm
always so critical
about
um celebrities who constantly talk about
you know representation and the things
that all this trouble in the world it's
like if this didn't affect your job you
would never say anything you don't
actually care you could always just shut
the [__] up and not say anything at all
you know you could just chill but you
know they they know that they say this
that they'll get glorified for it so
they'll do it it's just the Hollywood
cycle of things and you know are the art
kind of suffers for it yeah all the time
it happens all the [__] time
we're seeing like
their reasons and purposes
with Ellie's friend she
got
sewage Duty
so she's like look at my life in federal
the rest of my life I'm just gonna be
guarding a gate for people to shovel
[__] yeah you know and they have already
told you you're gonna be in the upper
you know officers you know like and I
I'll never get there if I'm down here
kind of thing which is just like the way
fascism I guess Works in their world
and um but despite you know whatever
background and beliefs they have they
have their moment together uh where they
kiss
that one beautiful moment that been
building up but just like the show does
immediately it takes it away from them
and one of the cordycep zombies shows up
they fight it off they think they've won
but they're both bit Yeah and Ellie this
is before she even knows she's immune
you know and then they have a talk
together about
well what do they do now they said
there's two options it's like we blow
each other's brains out right now or we
just continue
right she's like what do you mean
continue there's nothing like that for
this
you know she's like
you know whatever happens happens it's
like we just keep going on we live as
what we know we are and then we just
lose our minds together
right and what's option three there's no
option three so she cries in their arms
and it just goes to Black and we catch
back up to Ellie at the staircase
and she goes frantically looking for
some medicine something to patch him up
and she finds like a needle and thread
goes in there and do it does a [__]
Rinky Dink so job you know [__] him up
but you know sews him up and then
um
basically just sits and waits there and
then the episode ends so I could see why
this is a very
unlikable episode for a lot of people
yeah yeah where it's kind of like
nothing happened nothing happened
anticlimactic but I get it you know what
I mean I think this was this was
literally the worst rated episode so
people were just dying for the next one
like hurry up and end this [__]
episode so I can see what happens next
right
and then
in the next episode
where are we starting
this is she's in the house so she's in
the house she's patching she has to go
out and look for food yeah right this
episode by the way is [__] nuts right
right okay yes yes yes yes episode eight
this [__] religious episode episode
is [__] nuts this one was the highest
rated of the season so it's like back to
back a stinker and a great one yeah the
best one of this
obviously we're gonna you know break
this episode down but
my God this episode [__] wrecked me
yeah there was just so much going on in
one
with like all this deception and
manipulation where even in the audience
we bought into this character David
his manipulation for the first minute
right he seemed like the kindest person
ever like he's either like a
misunderstood human being that has like
the best intentions for things right so
Ellie is has to go hunt for food right
and in the previous episode we didn't
mention this but there was a part where
Joel had like this moment with Ellie
where he's teaching her how to use the
rifle right because he fell asleep while
he was supposed to guard and she was
like you fell asleep so I'm doing it so
she wants to take up more responsibility
and learn how to survive so she actually
kills like a deer or a stag or whatever
it is right uh along the way there are
two other people that are there
and they see her kill but they don't
know who killed this deer yeah Ellie
being a [__] gangster is like yo back
the [__] up she basically has a bad gun
Point yeah and has him throw away their
weapons and they kind of make a deal
like
um she basically finesses them and he
basically tells her throughout the
conversation that they have medicine
yeah right because she needs it so he's
like cool I'm gonna keep this guy
hostage you go get the medicine and then
what was it there we're gonna split
the the deer something like that yeah it
was some kind of deal right and this guy
David is being very [__] chill about
everything and he's dead honest he's
keeping it real like he tells dude go
back to the camp and get uh two shots of
penicillin he's like it's not a code
like it's not just go and don't do it
you know and you see him just kind of
questioning his choices like what the
[__] what do you mean it's not a code
just go get the penicillin which is what
she needs because he has this infection
yeah and that's the thing that's going
to help him
so
I think it cuts to them they made a
little fire and they have their own
little conversation right and he talks
about like sheep drops like what are you
in some cult he's like yeah I'm actually
a preacher but I'm a good guy you know
I'm just I they chose me to be their
leader
you know and they want you know and so
I'm taking care of just this communal
people you know you should actually come
and join us and you know she does her
thing like [__] you
and then
he's
so honest in fact
that
he says you know knowing that you need
this medication you know there was
someone in our camp
you know who died fighting some guy
who's you know who he stabbed and they
said he had a little girl with her and
then she's like oh [__] like that's me
right he's like see I know this whole
time you know but I'm just you know I
just want peace too you know let's let's
chill out
and then dude comes with a gun and
David still tells his guy his name is
James he's like Put the gun down give
him medication and she runs he's so
confused yeah so James says what are you
doing yeah right
so
Ellie goes down there and she shoots him
up with the penicillin ironically
penicillin comes from
fungus yeah yeah so it saves Joel's life
um
obviously she has no idea what the [__]
she's doing you know and um I think time
passes so they go back to the camp to
get more men
right and then she uh
uh is puts in the next dose I think the
next day
and when she goes out to get water or
snow for water or something she sees
that these men are in the neighborhood
looking for her yeah she tries to make a
run for it on the horse the James dude
shoots the horse
knocking Ellie over and she gets knocked
out and then they see her and they're
like let's kill her yeah right and even
though David already had made a point
don't kill her kill her right
and James is about to kill her and then
he catches them it's awesome killing her
picks her up and he says I'm going back
to the camp you two drag that [__]
horse because you're probably gonna eat
it yeah
yeah well you know we should we should
go back to the intro of David too
because when he's introduced they're in
their commune like a steakhouse right
it's like a big restaurant so
everybody's Cabin Restaurant or
something yeah and he's giving the verse
from Revelation about what you know this
what heaven is like what the new kingdom
is basically you know there will be no
more tears or death or sadness
and the girls crying because her dad
died
and then she just asks them can we bury
him now yeah immediately and he looks
over and they're like well no the ground
is too cold and hard we'll wait till
spring to bury him
and so
um we we see that they're not in good
condition they're starving people right
so that's why they're always out there
and then I guess we get the information
that they only have like five weeks left
of food so yeah of venison
and
um David
questions James's Faith like are you
still in it with me right are you still
following me to see if James has his
trust but then you see how that's
contended when James isn't listening to
him trying to kill this girl
and so what we learn is like they put
Ellie in a cage and David comes to talk
to her again
but
at least smarter this time the first
time in front of that fire when she was
so immersed with his manipulation
because he's a preacher right until he
reveals that hey I know who you are in
the same way he's trying to [__]
manipulate her about giving her a life
here and he says I see you as an equal
you know and what we're starting to
really see is like just that creepiness
he has about you or she wants her when
you were hearing him talk was it
irritating you because it was irritating
the [__] out of me like yeah yeah yeah I
think it's because I've had my fair
share of preachers I fell into because
there was such Dynamic speakers yeah and
then you realize you're kind of a piece
of [__] yeah yeah and I started
like it didn't really hit me until he
started talking to Ellie you know like
this promise like who are you doing this
for there's a there's a greater picture
that you don't really see you know I'm
like oh he's doing the [__] Pastor
talk the stuff that we used to get when
we were younger and they did it so
[__] well yeah it's so creepy like
I'm not even sure if that's what the
writer intended but they if they didn't
intend it then God damn you encapsulated
the Creepypasta really well 100 they
intended yeah because uh I was listening
in I mean I'll talk about it after we we
finished about this episode specifically
because
um I mean in the cage Ellie sees a
[__] ear yeah on the floor
and then previously
you know we saw them like cooking up a
stock and a guy brings a bucket full of
meat and then he just sarcastically he's
like more venison yeah
and so we're as the audience we're kind
of starting to piece it together
right what the [__] it actually is
because the next shot they bring in the
deer alley killed earlier so wait that's
not the tear yeah
right and they're sitting and waiting
and he
you know they come in to eat they give
the prayer
and
oh importantly when he comes in
everybody knows that they've caught this
girl so there's this weird vibe in the
air so he says yeah we're gonna this but
we're not gonna be violent we're gonna
bring Justice to them right
and then the girl whose father died
she wants Vengeance she's like we should
kill him we should kill him right now he
walks up and [__] smacks her
and then he says
like you might think you don't have a
father but you do right and this is that
religious manipulation and gas lighting
technique
where it's like they're talking about
God
you know when they talk about submitting
to Authority and stuff but narcissists
who run a church are talking about
themselves yeah when they say God in
reality they're trying to get through
your head that no you have to do what I
say because I'm saying what God says
yeah I am God yeah I am his vessel so
you're starting he's opening up more of
his character traits about what's going
on behind all of that front
in this guy and is getting more and more
creepy so when he's in that cage he's
trying that game again on Ellie but
Ellie is [__] smart she fell for it
the first time she's not gonna do it the
second time because she draws in closer
she's like yeah
oh and then grabs his finger and [__]
strikes that [__] she she [__] pulled
a fast one on him manipulated him into
believing her words
I thought that was pretty smart writing
to get what she wanted yeah I'm gonna
[__] you up no matter what yeah you know
and in that case it made him I think he
dropped the keys yeah right and then um
so he leaves the room threatens to chop
her up and eat her
and then I think she I forget if she
gets herself out or they they [__]
grab her
[__] I can't remember anyways well James
his assistant and David have her tied
down to the [__] butchering table
he's about to [__] chop her up with
this knife butcher's knife she goes I'm
infected and it shows him the [__]
bite to bite any looks but in doing that
he lets go of her arm
so she grabs the [__] Cleaver and
whacks it over and hits [__] James
right in the neck that clavicle bone
right there and she books out of there
and David doesn't even give a [__] yeah
he never cared about James he always
looked at him with content I think he
looked at everyone in that camp you're
not equal to yeah this is what the
writers of the show were saying like
nobody's equal to him except what he saw
on Ellie but the way he saw it wasn't
like come reign with me in this [__]
[__] commune forever is just that
doesn't matter I want you yeah I have to
have you just [__] manic narcissist
creepy to the max yeah
and I think that cuts towards Joel's
situation there was a two other guys
searching for him
and Joel is getting better because of
the penicillins was working and he hears
them coming into the home
and so he hides out in the basement and
even in his weakest state
he's
chilling smart my lovely genius farts
during this Prime spring season you need
wholesome convenient meals to energize
you for warmer more active days and keep
you on track to reaching your goals Sun
Factor America's number one ready to eat
meal kit can help you feel a fast with
Ready-to-Eat meals deliver straight to
your door you'll save time eat well and
Tackle everything on your to-do list
look if you're too busy to cook this
made with factors skip the trip to the
grocery store and Skip The Chopping
preppy and all that other BS factors
fresh never frozen meals are just ready
in uh two minutes and they freaking
taste delicious I actually got sent a
bunch of them I destroyed all of them
because they were so good and it's based
on the convenience I like convenient
delicious food and the cool thing about
factor that I personally enjoy the most
my friends is they have 34 plus Chef
prepared dietitian approved weekly
options so if you get tired of something
else you can try something new head to
factorymeals.com50 and use code genius
spray 50 to get 50 off your first box
that's code genius brain 50 at factory
50 to get 50 off your first box
my lovely genius farts this podcast is
brought to you by zoc doc my friends
you're trying to find a cause for your
symptoms and you stumble down a
Tick-Tock Rabbit Hole full of
questionable advice from so-called s
Birds well guess what that 13 year old
doesn't know booty there are better ways
to get the answers you want and the care
you deserve from trusted professionals
and not random little children on the
internet that thinks your pimple on your
face is something more than it actually
is my friends ZocDoc is the only free
app that lets you find a book doctors
who are patient reviewed take your
Assurance are available when you need
them and treat almost every condition
Under the Sun let me tell you something
I'm a bit of a hypochondriac and I love
ZocDoc for that I want my information
especially when it comes to my health to
come from licensed professional doctors
my friends and that's why I love zoc doc
go to zocdoc.com Jesus and download the
ZocDoc app for free the vinement book
top rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that
zocdoc.com genius that's zocdoc.com
genius
foreign
death blow like that neck like knife
right to the neck like the [__] Vegas
tobacco shop yeah you know
and then he can't even hold his own
weight down and falls on him and that
guy had the [__] gnarliest death yeah
where it's like I don't know if he was
smiling or some [__] but that was such a
[__] creepy death dude this this
whole is unaffected this whole scene
so this kind of always this kind of ties
back to
you know for me when his brother Tommy
was talking and every you know the
writing was alluding to how much of a
monster Joel is yeah you know yeah and
we've seen glimpse of this yeah and
obviously we'll see this later on in the
episodes too you'll see even even the
bigger picture of how why people knew
who he was like you have to understand
fedra is huge why do people know Joel so
[__] well you know what I mean yeah
like how come why does he have this
reputation it's probably ruthless
ruthless and you see it in this [__]
moment and obviously now now Not only
was he heartless before but imagine his
level of killing when he's not heartless
and he has something to care for now
yeah it's different now dude the way
that he killed it always it shook me a
little bit right because I'm always he's
a human being and I'm expecting to have
some Humanity but it's like it's gone
it's gone if you [__] with Ellie dude
but Bill alluded to that in the letter
he's like no motherfucker's gonna get in
our way of our purpose yeah that's how
you and I are like and now we're seeing
it he had this so in this scene
um for those of you who haven't watched
this and are listening to this it was so
vicious because he has his buck knife
stabbed into this guy's thigh right and
he's extracting information because he's
trying to find out camp and it's like yo
if you lie I'll [__] know and I'm
gonna kill you
that's a knife and he puts it in his
mouth and he hasn't point at it right he
goes I'm gonna have your buddy point at
the same spot and if you're lying you're
[__] done
and he points at the spot because
obviously he wrenches that night yeah he
points at the spot he goes thanks and he
[__] stabs him right through his
chest anyways and his friend he's like
Jesus why did you kill him and he's tied
up and it's like yo yo what am I
watching yeah it's like he's like why'd
you do that he's crying for his friend
he's like he told you where it was and
he goes I know I believe him and he
[__] bashes his hashes his head and
oh my God the Great and the sick part
about this is when Joel kills look at
his face
nothing nothing
wrong nobody's home when you see other
people who murder somebody in films
right even when it's like like
psychopath you either see them enjoy it
you see some kind of strange or
something they're like scrunching their
face before they swing full force Joel
is dead
it's so creepy yeah right stabs him no
facial expression smashing the dude's
head in no facial expression he doesn't
[__] care
and so Joel now that he knows where that
their commune is
makes his way there but we cut back to
the steakhouse and
Ellie is hiding from David and it's kind
of a indoor kind of wild goose not wild
goose chase but there is he's stalking
her and she's trying to hide
she throws this
log from the fireplace at him misses but
it catches a curtain on fire but now the
whole Steak House is burning up
and he's giving his bad guy monologue in
a situation where he's just like I don't
give a [__] on anything or any of this
[__] like I want you I got to have you
you're like mine and then even that
point of
what he's alluding to is he's gonna
rape her yeah and he's just like I like
you when they fight back
and she's screaming for her life because
he has her pinned down
but he I think she she ran up and
stabbed them earlier with her little
knife
and made him drop that Cleaver now when
when he's has her pinned down
she he's like ripping our clothes off
and she reaches up and grabs that
[__] Cleaver and [__]
smacks him he falls over
she jumps up top of them
and then the Flames get bigger and
brighter and stronger and she does not
stop chopping his [__] face in
and it's just she goes that Joel berserk
mode yeah he goes there
and she leaves the fire the burning
building on her own and she's in
complete shock and that's where Joel
catches her he's late
but he sees her alive and he Embraces
her and he calls her baby girl yeah and
he hasn't said that since he called his
daughter that
because she's you're safe now you're
safe now baby girl
cut to Black
and you're just like
yeah
you're watching
Ellie's Joel movement yeah of her losing
her Humanity now and that whole thing of
watching that preacher just with the
whole building burning down it's like an
allegory to hell like it's hell you know
what I mean yeah he was saying he was
like the Fallen Angel yeah and like he's
being revealed like this is who he truly
is like his true self was revealed when
everything was burning down right
because he I think he also said that he
became who he was he
after the apocalypse he said it was a
blessing yes he said it was a blessing
because he understands the cordyceps
because he's that kind of control freak
narcissist that he wants to get into
people's minds and control them and this
was what the creators of the show were
talking about on the their podcast it's
like look we make no qualms about it
last episode you saw communism work yeah
and I'm showing you theocracy has its
flaws but in reality he's saying like
you know we see how theocracy works like
in other countries or even the way the
the Christian right politically works
even in our own country
and the thing with religious people in
power
whether it's a thick theocracy or just a
church organization is that
you need a dynamic speaker preacher that
usually mostly comes with narcissistic
personality disorder yeah so you have
these religious organizations run by
people who aren't exactly qualified to
run it but they're just larger in life
people are still drawn to that because
they're prophets yeah they're that
profits like the people who could lead
them through something that they can't
understand
and
yeah it was
it was quite interesting because
it's not
that way because they're religious
they had they were dealt a bad card
their location because they're in a
resort what was a resort I guess at the
beginning of you know when all the [__]
went down with the Apocalypse
like they found this Resort that was
like secluded and all that it's perfect
place to be in the summer but in the
winter there's nothing yeah there's no
deer to hunt or anything
you know because it's too cold they've
probably all migrated you know and so
they suffer
and what we see is
because while Joel was out looking for
Ellie
they're eating humans yeah
they're straight up eating humans and
not telling anybody
so when you watch this the second time
and you already had a clear context of
what's going there didn't it wasn't it
all even creepier no 100 because of what
they're hiding yeah yeah yeah yeah like
watching it all over again and watching
people just eat that meal they don't
know what the [__] is going on like some
people are scarfing it down but the
people who know are like just eating the
soup and the tomatoes yeah like
it was weird like
you know when they when things are
attached to religion obviously it hits a
spot that we kind of grew up in right
and he
David reminds me of like in the Bible of
the false prophet right it's you think
it's Jesus Christ but he's Satan yeah
right and like I said when that whole
building came burning down it was almost
like reveal of like the the curtain it
was unveiled it's like this isn't Heaven
this is hell this is ill and this and
I'm in control of it I'm Satan and it
was [__] creepy as hell to me just
watching that whole thing going down and
even when I when I went back and I
watched the second time watching Ellie
hold the gun shoot and try to control
the situation she was just an amateur
version of Joel she's trying to reflect
everything Joel would do yeah you know
being the boss saying things very firmly
but she's so novice and amateur at it
she's fumbling through everything yeah
yeah right so she's just like a little
baby version of him and you see her
starting to morph into him a little bit
you know but that growth and morphing
into that in order to survive is
incredibly tragic yeah and what you have
to go through to lose your Humanity that
way
you know but it makes you stronger makes
you survive right
so yeah that was one that was probably
the best episode of this season for me
dude it was it was creepy it was sad it
was it answered a lot of questions
mysterious it was like it was so much
and that guy who played David [__]
killed it that's what I'm saying yeah
the guy played James plays Joel in the
video game he's the voice actor oh
really yeah yeah that's crazy oh what
the [__] I didn't even know that so
there's these little cameos from people
who are in the game playing different
roles in the show that's what I'm
learning this is what I'm talking about
like the the caliber of acting in this
um even think about the two guys that
died that that Joe murdered yeah yeah
dude that's that's the best dime I've
ever seen in my life yeah you know they
everybody [__] kills it in this in
this project for sure because good
writing doesn't matter if there's no
good acting that's involved with it and
the other way around too yup yup you
know and I'm I'm really getting to see
I've been watching a lot of like bad
[__] recently um just because people
have asked us to watch bad things and I
I sometimes I get lost I'm like is this
because of the writing or is it because
of the acting right you know is like
because somebody who's a really good
actor could they have executed this
um you know what I mean yeah and so I
sometimes I can't tell but this thing
everything is meshing so well together
and like I feel for every character even
when I don't even know them hmm you know
because they make it so visceral and
real real like or it kind of reminds me
of sometimes like who it makes me think
who would I be in this apocalypse
you know would I want to be somebody who
was a leader would I just be a follower
or like if I was in federal like in
Ellie's case right where he said like
just do [__] well and then you'll
just work on an office job and you'll
you don't even have to worry about
what's going on out there would I be
that person could I just ignore
everything it makes me wonder what my
place would be in this like despotic
world yeah you know yeah and
yeah so I thought these last
the the last the six seven eight were
interesting episodes for us to start
opening up and see these three different
situations you know what federal was
really like
you know and then what a communist
commune is like
and then what this theocracy is like
because yeah if if we just lost our
federal government people will huddle
together anyway yeah and figure out
their own little city states and then
have to come up with their own laws in
their own way to get together and you're
you're you're seeing the difference of
why the commune the Communist commune
worked
the Tommy's wife I care what's her name
is
um yeah I forget but she says that she
was the district attorney
you know and then when she lost her kid
and all that and the thing is everything
about who she is and what she knows is
the law and how important the law is and
it was the separation of church and
state you know with a theocracy it is
the marriage of church and state yeah
and the writers were very intentionally
trying to show like look there's these
flaws here too although even like a
utopic communist country doesn't exist
either yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
like at the same time it's just like you
gotta look at it as just sci-fi in the
way it is
and so now we're coming into episode
nine the last episode the opening scene
a pregnant woman is running
for her life
she finds this
abandoned rotten home
she tries to block the door in
and she just waits in the corner and
she has at least knife
right
and then yeah zombie bust through the
door and they she fights It Off
stabs that saw me in the head with that
knife
and then it dies but then you see she's
been bit
on her leg and at the same time in that
fight
she just popped out the baby yeah
and she gathers the baby up she cuts the
umbilical cord
brings a baby in and he says Ellie
you're so strong
you know and it's like oh [__]
and
I don't know if to you if the actress
playing the pregnant lady is familiar
but she is the voice of Ellie in the
video game 10 years ago
and now she's playing Ellie's Mom isn't
that beautiful how [__] crazy is that
like the guys who made this were just
like so spot on on these things still
they say they wrote this from the game
right but it's not interactive at all it
would have been this really long cut
scene so they took it out of the game
and then they're like it's way too
important like you just gotta put it in
the show so they added this this scene
and then we see someone familiar Marlene
a firefly leader
and she comes up stairs and sees
um her like
with a baby and they're cautious because
she's clearly bit she lies to her and
she says
I got
a bit after I cut the cord yeah after
you have to
let her live and then she asked Marlene
to shoot her that kill her
and she can't so she walks away with the
baby hands the baby to the soldier
and you can hear her screaming Marlene
just begging begging to kill her
she runs back in tears and eyes and just
you know and we
cut to present
and
I think some time has passed again
um
and
where they're walking towards are they
already walking towards a city now it's
like a city it's like this thing is
Colorado State University yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're at a college
because they have that dialogue or
she's like what the hell is college and
it's like it's where people go to figure
out who they want to be and what they
want to do with their life
and Ellie says
figure out what they want to do with
their life yeah and you think about it
like huh
this whole thing with college and the
way it is in America or in many places
at the end of the day it does sound so
extracurricular yeah yeah yeah but then
we do it like our life depends on it you
know like we've been told like this is
the most important thing you have to do
you know what's interesting about this
episode like is Joel's [__]
personality is so different
how he treats her how he speaks to her
is almost like
he's
he's Ellie now and Ellie is here you're
right because look in the beginning he's
trying to tell her jokes he's trying to
get her to laugh she's priority exactly
you know what I mean teach you how to
play guitar
yeah he's just he's they kind of like
flip positions and she kind of feels
indifferent
you know what I mean the rolls kind of
flipped and I'm like oh he's like vying
for attention and love which wasn't
there before you know yeah it didn't
seem like I thought that he almost lost
her it didn't seem buddy buddy it was
because before Ellie was trying to get
it and now like I think what people
would kind of expect is them now being
on the same page where they're just like
a loving relationship but you kind of
don't see that you kind of see Joel
being Ellie you know like hey this is a
snapper yeah he's like talking he's
yapping so [__] much trying to fill
in the silence in this weird void
but Ellie is still reeling from the
trauma of what happened in the last
episode that's what we're seeing
but then a beautiful scene happens
um it's like shot for shot from the game
I remember seeing this clip when they
find the giraffe oh yeah all the animals
yeah like
um I think that brings back a lot of the
humanity into
Ellie
but Ellie
going through what she had just went
through
talks about how far they've come ready
and she reiterates like we're seeing
this through
we've come this far we're gonna go
through with I'm going through with it
all the way we need to find the
fireflies
so the head back down they find like a
emergency like medical encampment that's
been abandoned and
they get into the conversation about
Joel scar on his head
and he had previously I guess told her
that somebody tried to shoot him and he
killed him instead
and then he clarifies that actually you
know I try to
it was myself
after his daughter had died you know
um
and then he says that he flinched the
last second and so he missed shooting
himself
so he survived
and then
he says he's kind of giving that same
platitude it's like I moved on and I
kept living I just kept trying to
survive it was I guess that was a good
enough reason
and she's like I get it like Time Heals
all wounds
and he looks at her and he's like it
wasn't time
and it's unspoken clearly Joel's saying
like Ali healed yeah you know
and
okay and then they kind of break the
tension because they're both not that
vulnerable type to each other yet so
it's that Dad joke moment again
and when I saw that Dad joke moment I'm
like dude this guy is
soft I was like look at that dude he
found like his love again like he found
his reason for living again yeah and for
me that's such a
it's I'm happy for him but it's
it's a bad sign because he's still a
monster
um you know but like I said people are
scared of the person who has people you
think you're scared of the person who
has nothing to live for you should be
scared of the person who has something
to do something to lose yeah that is the
most frightening person especially in
this world where that one thing that he
can't lose is one person he isn't that
if you were scared of him before he
should be scared of him now yeah you
know so as they're walking away from the
medical encampment
um we see some foot soldiers walking in
the background creeping up on them and
they [__] Counter-Strike their ass
you know flash bomb flash bomb
um knock them out
Joel wakes up in the
College Medical Campus
and Marlene's there
waiting for him to wake up
you know and she's like hey everything's
good and all this stuff like
can't believe you made it this far you
know like I literally didn't think you
were gonna make it and he's like I was
all Ellie
and you know she's trying to like be
like okay you can be on your way and
he's like wait what where's Ellie yeah
right
and he's like well they're prepping her
for surgery
like surgery for what like and then she
explains the science of
how the doctor can manipulate whatever
quadricep that's in her since birth that
sends these signals to be immune to
cordyceps that come into the body
and then Joel says but it crows in the
brain
like I know right and he starts flipping
out so they gotta [__] subdue him for
a second
and he's begging at that point like you
don't understand and she says I do
understand
she does understand more than anybody
because she was there today she was born
yeah and she had to kill her own friend
yeah but the thing is
her friend
also asked her to save her daughter's
life to help her live yeah
but because of this cure she's going
against what her best friend says to
save Ellie's life and to kill her to
save the world so she's like I
understand
exactly what you're going through but
I'm making this decision we have to do
this
you know so we can end this we could
save the world
and there's no option for Joel they've
taken his weapons so they March him out
but in the stairwell
[__] Bing Bang Boom
[__] him up shoots one guy shoots the
other guy in the lake says where is she
he's like [__] you I don't have time for
this boom boom Blossom you know what's
interesting too goes on his ramp I was
talking you know earlier about
Joel's reputation right and do you
remember what she said to him she goes
out of all the people that we're gonna
bring her here he was like I I never
wanted to be you she was like I did not
want to be in debt to you of all people
his reputation is nuts yeah you got to
understand that right she looks at him
like [__] and I think because of the
game being interactive if you did play
the game that's you yeah you're the one
doing all the killing so you would
understand what they that when they talk
about his reputation
now
this is part of the this is one of the
most
oh video game aspects of the show to
this point is when he goes on his
Rampage
and he kills everybody no not like
complete but like he goes to anybody up
in front of him he's taking him out like
you would in a video game
but what you're hearing is sad music
yeah the score is this sad cello like
what Joel is doing is a tragedy
he
for him
save the world or save Ellie easiest
choice in the world yeah save Ellie for
him it's that's it we've seen him in his
panic attacks because
you know of him being a failure and
losing and he almost lost Ellie again
and she got herself out of that and you
could see his response to that after she
had saved his life
it's a no-brainer for him
[__] the world this is it he cannot lose
any more he can't lose anything anymore
you know
and
goes back and just does a rampage the
guy [__] puts his gun down puts his
hands up to surrender pow pow Saving
Private Ryan like like just kills him
and then he gets to the [__]
operating room
and there's these nurses and a doctor
there
and he finds out Lee and he's like
release her
and doctors like grabs a scalpel
I'm not gonna let you take her boom
killed the only man on this [__]
planet who could save the world he does
not give a [__] that was the biggest
tell sign when he killed I actually
thought I was like well the doctor's
gonna live yeah you know give him
another chat like I said give a [__]
yeah kill real shot the last chance that
anybody has a survival and he doesn't
[__] care
you know
when we talk when we see something you
know we've talked about narcissism
you know this is something else this is
like there's narcissism and then there's
this like this guy is just fighting
everything is for himself it seemingly
seems like he's for Ellie yeah it's for
his sanity yes I cannot fail
it's not I want to save Ellie I can't
lose again I can't lose
you know nothing [__] literally
nothing [__] matters at this point
and then you see it towards the end this
is the part where I was like okay
they're at The Stance he's holding Ellie
right she's in a robe and then who's
there Marlene Marlene is there Marlene
is right there and listen this is such a
weird moment right because throughout
this whole storyline we've gotten to
know Joel we've gotten to know Ellie we
get to see who he is we've humanized him
all this other stuff right
but we're literally we we are forgetting
that this is still the end of the
[__] world um this is the end of the
[__] world yeah and the savior is
Ellie right
here the the weird conflicting part
about this and you're going to see this
towards the end is that nobody is
considering what Ellie wants yeah yeah
the conversation isn't even brought up
it's just save the world or or Joel is
going to fail at his mission and that's
really about it and then you just have
this person in the middle who's just
dangling in Joel's arm but nobody's
asking what is what does Ellie want even
Marlene didn't give her the option but
she said they didn't even tell her what
they're gonna do to her they just put
her to sleep and so she wouldn't even
know what the [__] was gonna happen to
her dad woken up also in hearing that
conversation that Ellie was having with
Joel I'm 100 sure Ellie would have said
yes
I felt yeah because after that draft
since she was telling him yeah I'm
seeing this through 100 you came this
far
but I think Joel knowing if if Ellie
were to be given an option she would do
it would have done it until you finally
have a reason for having lived this
weird [__] up life in this reality you
have to have murdered people to have
killed people you know all of that and
she has a purpose and reason but then
Joel's like but you're my purpose and
reason yeah
yeah and so
that's why there's the sad music playing
and what Marlene calls out is that you
can't protect her forever
people and there's this is interesting
that they took out from the game they
said somebody else will be after her you
know who's next if the cordyceps don't
come after her you know or Arters
murderers and in the game she says
rapists
but they took it out on the show because
I thought was weird like literally last
episode like yeah she almost got you
know man
um
and she's trying to reality check Joel
but
she's sitting there giving a man an
option
when he's already made up his mind yeah
and so bow he shoots her
and then but what happens is it cuts to
him in the car
and she wakes up from a day he's like
what the [__] what's going on where are
my clothes and then he tells this
fabricated lie
he says
that there was a bunch of other people
just like you
and they couldn't find a cure so they
stopped the program but when you were
under
Raiders came and had to fight him off
there was no time so that's why we're
here
it's like
I mean Ellie's not that stupid well
Ellie's smart yeah she knows something
is up
you know she's like well what happened
to Marlene
all right yeah yeah and then she just
goes back to sleep and he says I'm sorry
flash back to what happened
she calls out to him one more time
you know
but
this is Joel thinking ahead too how
she's like let me live please just let
me live he'll just come after us it
would just come after us
hardness dude
this is this so when you see them you
know at the towards the end of this
episode they're hiking right they're
going up in this Trail it's talking
about his daughter troll
obviously now he's so nervous because he
lied yeah he's just [__] word vomit
like a [__] right which is
unlike him unlike him at all like you
thought he was weird before but he was
trying to be all like lovey-dovey and
[__] he is panicking now like in his
weird it's it's like his anxiety is up
right where he's trying to just it's not
even him trying to cheer her up it
reminded me of I don't know if it's like
what is that called when he's just
giving her this
love
but it's like manipulation yeah you're
trying to build up this
off the back of a lie yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's just it's it's terrible you
see his anxiety building up and it's so
out of character remember
throughout this whole series you know
how sharp and smart Ellie is so she asks
him you know basically to tell her the
truth and she's giving him a chance to
be honest and what does he do
[__] lies lies again just like
when she
tries to speak to him
for real ever like because yeah so much
of the beginning of a relationship is
just her bullshitting all the time
sarcasm 24 7.
and
this is you know why
Ellie chose Joel too why she was
attached to Joel
was because she was saying everybody
leaves her
she said um
I'm so sorry I forgot her girl's name
the girl she cares back at the mall
test
no and Marlene now or whatever or if she
said some another another name like a
third person I don't know why it's
blinking but oh Sam the deaf kid
and then her point was that Joel never
left her and that's why she chooses him
but then he starts giving these
platitudes
you know about once again yeah you know
you lose somebody but then you just got
to keep going and then you'll find
somebody new
you know and she's like oh like you
could see it on her face she's like
this is not what she's trying to hear
from him right now but then like he's
building saying all this [__] off the
back of a lie so she finally just says
it to his [__] face like because
everything you said about the fireflies
true
and this like
it's simple dialogue is this true and he
says yes
okay and they walk right but everything
in between those lies is what you have
to read in their [__] faces yeah
we know Joel's lying
but does Ellie believe Joel in that very
last shot of her
right
and the way I read it just felt like she
just doesn't believe him yeah but she is
and I think the seed was actually
planted in the episode uh Tommy's wife
remember the advice that she gave her
right it's like the people who are
closest to you not that hurt the demo
they lie they lie and they deceive you
they're the ones that could [__] you up
the most that was the one little advice
that she gave her right right because
she was the one vehemently defending
Joel she was like you don't know him she
goes I'm like I I know I know people
like him and she was look I'm gonna just
say one last thing
all these other people can hurt you but
the people that are closest to you are
the one that would [__] you up the most
and then she kind of left it at that and
you could see that
what she's trying to say is the reason
why Tommy left Joel right and why he's
just
hey hey welcome back into my life right
and then
in like you're saying Ellie now
understands what she's talking about
because what she said was like that's
because Tommy's stupid yeah back then
but then it's like wait am I stupid
she's smart man smart that that episode
ending right there I was like God damn
it I want one more [__] episode I
want to see how this [__] unravels
man
Last of Us Part Two
after re-watching this
like like I said I played the first game
and I vowed never to play again because
it's too scary for me I don't like scary
games and then I finished this and I was
like [__] like you're saying I want more
yeah and there is a part two out there I
just have to play the game and just
Facebook I'll play this game is if I
have a cheat code where I can't die
amen right hey guys write it in the
comments do you want to see David play
Last of Us Part Two and stream it
I'm just going to be screaming and it's
just going to be peaking the whole time
yeah just screaming
let's do it this show is so damn good
they do such a good job of just tying
everything so neatly yeah and giving you
just enough where you want more I I
haven't
really enjoyed like it I've been trying
to watch a lot of things right and like
I've enjoyed a lot but this show is
[__] amazing yeah
um
and the way
just how the show ended up not being
about zombies yeah it ended up being
about the people and of humanity in when
we're in survival mode like what are we
down to our Primal selves yeah because
the answer is already clear like what's
gonna happen a zombie movie we're gonna
run away from these things they're gonna
try to kill us that Trope has been done
a million times over we [__] get it
like like I said earlier in the podcast
the biggest thing that I I have to do or
that I think about in the show
is what I would do in their situation
that's why I just keep thinking about
yeah where would I be where would I be
placed in this situation well I've
already done a sketch on being bit by a
zombie
I
you know I joke about the stuff but in
reality it seems so real I don't know
where I would be placed you know would I
would I lean towards my religious side
because I need hope and that's what
religious right you know that's what
religion does for you it gives you hope
outside of this [__] reality that
you're living in right now because
you're hoping for something outside of
this yeah yeah so that's why it was
interesting with David saying how he
found
you know Chris or Christ or God after
the what they say the apocalypse is you
know
I think I told the story before about
the guy I met when I was in Iraq
he
was
a convert after September 11th
he said after September 11th he became a
Christian
and then him
find like being gone okay so if I'm a
Christian like what does it say what am
I supposed to do
and he realized the war in Iraq is
unjust
and so therefore he should go there and
be a missionary and live there crazy and
he's the guy that I learned
um to just cuss as a Christian whatever
[__] it you know because it doesn't
change like what we think and feel and
believe like this is what we truly
believe in our hearts expressed through
our mouths
but yeah like in that way the way I was
so influenced by him
because of
you know some people radiate that energy
like I can understand these
being in David's car yeah
following this guy this guy seems to get
it
hey can I go bury my mom
I picture me just like in a in a [__]
suit and Ty just doing accounting
professional yeah like hey people are
dying I was like never heard of it I
don't know what you're talking about hey
I saw we still have a basketball gym
anyone want to play something later yeah
cool that's the thing we had to see
about Pedros like they have a [__]
school of basketball team they're
they're what we saw before was was very
apocalyptic outside but then you see
what they mean by Fascism and class that
there's these workers down here who do
this [__] grunt work and then there's
the people in federal who live in the
top of the high tower and get all the
benefits from that and then that this is
then translated to looking at the
Communist commune how they're kind of
perpetuating this uh Economist Utopia
yeah in a way
it's when you listen to the HBO official
podcast the writers are like no qualms
about talking about how they don't like
theocracy and hey maybe communism give
it a shot so they're liberal as [__]
oh yeah communism always works out great
guys I'm evidently yeah I've seen a
there was this a clip of this guy
um
he basically
you know walked up to a bunch of people
who were you know touting like socialism
and communism this guy like is from like
he escaped like communism he's like what
the [__] are you talking about because
you you don't know what the [__] you're
saying he's like I've escaped communism
for a reason you know Cuban yeah if you
meet a Cuban and you they hate oh
[__] God that's why there's such
strong Trump supporters yeah it's not
about
you know like
any of the [__] [__] that
everybody else hates about Trump it's
they're just Cubans are just so
pro-america yeah and Donald Trump is the
one who is that guy yeah yeah yeah it
just reminds them of of a country that
in a regime that tried to try to escape
you know so whatever is anti that
they're gonna go for that so you talk to
anybody who escaped the communist
country they're just be like what the
[__] are you talking about like if
communism was going to work it would
have worked in our country and all these
other countries but historically it
hasn't happened that way yeah right
you're giving all the power to what one
person
but like what the show is trying to
portray is down to its Bare Bones when
we as an idealistic communism we have no
more what we have now yeah and you're
gonna have pockets of these different
ideologies everybody shares everybody's
equal
and so that's why they're portraying
this idealistic version of Communism and
then they show like a theocracy off the
bat
yeah it's just it doesn't work it's
because you're gonna have a narcissistic
leader telling people this is what God
says so you have to listen to me which
is so funny that that's what they were
trying to go for but that's also
communism too
they're adopting that yeah that's
communism too because technically
everybody's sharing their meals right
but do you have one despotic leader that
[__] that's the thing you still need
a dictatorship in order to have
communism exactly kind of weird it's
really yeah so like every ideology has
its [__]
contradictions yeah you know
um but I think I think another point I
wanted to bring up about the show
oh [__] I forgot [__] I hate when that
happens
but it was definitely had to do with the
ideologies we live in down to our core
people as human beings
and I've lost it okay well guys that
wraps up this episode of The Genius
brain podcast with Ed breaking down
every [__] movie possible I'm sure I
forgot I'll write it in the comments
later yeah
um hope you guys enjoyed it I know it
was long awaited but Ed was in Seattle
for a whole month
and I don't like doing this with other
people because I don't think people
watch shows like we do in this into this
extent right you know so
um write in the comments below what you
thought about the latter half of the
season
um uh let us know other stuff that you
want us to review we will be doing beef
soon we still have to do Creed uh we
still have to do the bear there's a
whole bunch of stuff so much there's so
many other things that I want to talk
about and break down
um I'm really glad that you guys enjoy
these film and TV breakdowns because I
never actually thought people would have
enjoyed this that much yeah I think
covet changed that because everybody
fell into TV culture extreme culture you
know what I also found out from reading
in the comments is that I think we're
also uh crazy people because
I don't think people watch things the
way that we do we do and you watch
things more intensely than I do so I
didn't realize that you know because
when we say things right people go oh I
never thought oh [__] and I to me it's
just you know some sometimes a parent
yeah but maybe it's just we just I
thought about that too like
um
people will say oh Ed your life is so
crazy right and I don't I don't
necessarily think my life is any more
interesting than the next person I just
think I'm a pretty good Storyteller yeah
you know I just make it interesting yeah
yeah yeah and as a fellow Storyteller
like for us we grew up
and we were raised by television yes and
for people like you and I like other
kids too but you and I
we're imitating it we were recreating it
and so when we were doing that we were
deconstructing it and reverse
engineering it as we made it ourselves
you know what that's why we understand
what we're seeing now you know what I
realized too and how many years most
people don't re-watch things they never
grew up like us right I had to re-watch
things just to put it in perspective uh
before you know the the digitization of
media yeah right
um obviously this is even before our
time so for example my my one of my
former bosses from The Men's Warehouse
we we still keep in contact to this day
and he was telling me he remembers
um waiting in line to watch the the
first Star Wars right yeah and he waited
a whole day to watch that [__] and then
the next day he waited another whole day
to watch it he waited in line for 24
hours to watch this [__] and he watched
it three times in theaters over and over
and over again like when you watch like
amazing things they weren't coming out
every other day every hour on the
outside so much out there and it's
overwhelming when they say have you seen
this have you seen this exactly yeah
people would sit and they would watch
stuff and they would joy over and over
again and on top of that when we watched
the film guess how long it would take to
go to [__] VHS it would be like a
year and a half oh God it took forever
back in the day yeah like I remember for
Jurassic I was waiting for this
forever and like what and the thing was
Blockbuster would always get it first
you couldn't buy it you could only rent
it at the time so it was movies were
very exclusive back in the day and it's
so accessible now and there's content
everywhere like even just on YouTube
people people put up their whole hour
long I mean this podcast being like that
long too it's like you can put up
anything like your entire stand-up
special your entire movie but the fact
is like there's so much content that we
get overwhelmed when people tell us to
see stuff too yeah oh we have this and
this and this too but at the same time
the quality of the wide range of content
is much better yeah because
comment sections because social media
can [__] blast it so standard for
what's a good movie and a in a whatever
movie now it's like there's a clear line
drawn would be like what to expect and
what you're watching yeah yeah and so a
lot of people too having access to
you know podcasts like this
help them learn and understand and
translate what they're seeing on the
screen you know so like I think it's
just great for film culture in general
because really when we do this we want
people to understand why we love
something and when you learn to love it
like we do too you can go out there
check something else out and learn how
to love it on your own yeah and then
find your own reasons and draw your own
opinions as well yeah and it's okay to
expect more from the things that you're
watching too yeah right and I think that
one of the things that maybe I dislike
is when people give excuses to films
um for being poor quality yeah just for
being [__] yeah you know they go well I
can't do it well just because you can do
it doesn't mean that you're in their
position you know what I mean it's a
Marvel film what did you expect a bad
excuse like but they used to make
bangers exactly so if it wasn't done
great before I'd understand right like
this is like a certain standard but
we've already picked and named a whole
bunch that do what this the things that
we're saying is missing in these
terrible films yeah I feel that way with
X-Men movies it's a crap shoot it might
be [__] and it might be [__] great
yeah and so when I saw Fox Marvel then I
knew oh it's not MCU and then I'd have a
lower standard for them yeah right I
mean like I don't know if I ever brought
this up but did you know
we ran a video rental store
you your parents did yeah it's just like
Jay and Silent Bob like clerks oh for
real there's a quick stop like a a
convenience store next door video store
with movies what the [__] so it was open
for a few years of like from all
throughout Middle School to high school
after school every day I have to go to
the store with my dad on his shift and
then I go next door and I'm in I'm
[__] seventh grade home I am 12 13
years old and I'm running the video
store
and every [__] movie ever I dreamed
of as a poor kid my dad finally having
this business it was a dream come true
and now I had every movie I wanted at my
disposal and all the movies my dad
wouldn't let me watch they were just
like let me watch anything oh wow so in
seventh grade I saw Boogie Nights that's
why I was so influenced by that movie
yeah and I still think it's such an
amazing film you know it was one of the
most influential movies to me in that
day but that's where I learned like so
you know I saw Super Mario Brothers
right and I [__] loved it because the
thing is it made me flash back to 1993
when I went to go see it with my dad in
Flint Michigan
and he [__] hated it and he let me
know because he's an [__] like that
and I'm in some seven years old
and because he hated it so much after it
came out on VHS he wouldn't let us rent
it but John leguizama one yeah why do
you hate her so much because it's
[__] bad he knew it was bad for sure
yeah my dad was a big film buff yeah so
that I think it was his big dream to do
his own video into store because he
[__] hated Blockbuster you know like
paying money to rent and stuff it's like
now I got my own store so that's how we
grew up loving like movies too so every
day after school I get there at like
three or four p.m we close at 9pm I'm
watching movies and doing my homework
and that's where I learned to like
differentiate because I put in Super
Mario Brothers again and I learned this
movie's [__] [__] yeah
because when we grow up and we're
kids of immigrants and we grew up with
the TV and whatever is just on the first
13 channels right everyone in pop
culture from SNL to friends and sitcoms
all that they have a Godfather reference
a good fellow reference these movie
references like what are they talking
about so I have these movies now so I
watched Godfather and I watch Goodfellas
and I'm like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah this
is good yeah and Mario Brothers is [__]
oh Street Fighter [__] sucks oh my
God
that's when I really
had a fast track with my film love was
because like all the kids movies I left
behind you know re-watching Power
Rangers movies and you're like oh man
this is pretty good you know they
brought out a new Power Rangers movie
yeah the original cast what what what
with uh Billy and Zach
dude it's oh it was a comeback special
right let me tell you something
probably top five worst things I've ever
seen
all right we gotta watch this on Netflix
yeah
the first scene that you'll see alone
you're gonna die laughing okay like just
to set it up right somebody dies and you
know when somebody dies right you see
emotions or something right the person
dies they're just like oh man they're
dead
so that I [__] died laughing oh my
God some of the worst acting I've ever
seen in my life
but yeah like but how do you know it's
bad because you've seen so much that's
good yeah you know and so what through
all this [__] like wow this is a
long-winded closing just to say like I'm
super thankful that I keep getting to
come back and keep talking about movies
because before this I used to write long
ass [__] essays and dissertations on
Facebook like paragraphs and paragraphs
and paragraphs breaking down movies
because I couldn't get it off my chest
yeah and then I'd come here and then you
gave me the space to finally [__]
talk about the Matrix
get off my [__] chest I'll be trying
to talk about movies to Mariel and I'd
never seen somebody just fall out of
love
She [__] hates it yeah she [__] it
but I'll tell you this though because of
the way that I'm watching things now and
now she's watching things with me
she said that I ruined things for her
now because she's saying things she's
saying what's a faux pas in film like
what's not right why do they do that
that doesn't make any sense this is so
dumb and she's like she's like these
um Korean dramas are not as enjoyable as
they used to be right because you
[__] open time I just kind of opened
it up a little bit because she didn't
understand she goes why can't you just
enjoy it I was like listen once that
door's open you can't close it yeah
right it's just dumb we're not like
trying to make you make make people like
ruin content for other people but
understand the standard yeah yeah and
you got to understand too I like a lot
of dumb [__] like I said one of my
favorite movies of all time it's Nacho
Libre Nacho Libre man you know so it's
not like I don't like dumb things
crippled Avengers crippled Adventures
too
they're crazy that [__] show you guys go
find that on Amazon go on Amazon and
watch crippled Avengers and thank us
later it's [__] the most ridiculous
it's basically like Instagram [__] uh
real comedy put into a film but what's
crazy is how you can see Tarantino's
influenced by it like you're like oh
[__] Tarantino bit that yeah yeah when
you okay just the ultimate biter by the
way yeah uh yeah but you guys could
catch DJ spring every Sundays at 12 p.m
and you can catch Ed at edparkvp and not
breakfast at Momos but Bible studies
yeah
um we'll see you all next time peace
peace